what would you like to say
that would like to say
happy birthday to an amazing woman for
Tamar Braxton's birthday this year she
got a fiance same Tamar's day
now you were telling me good things
happened on your birthday magical things
one of those magical things ringing her
46th year with a life partner Tamar's
new fiance attorney Jeremy J.R Robinson
it's just the beginning of your birthday
but you're gonna have fun in New York
and Miami and Atlanta
here's to
46. let the fun begins
Tamar met her King on peacock's Queens
Court their love blossomed into a
proposal two more
oh my God I love you Tamar
and the lead will you marry me
something told me to trust the process
and I've never done anything like this
before and what's the worst that can
happen I find love yeah that's exactly
what happened talk about a royal
surprise oh I'm crazy about you James
foreign
so what exactly did you learn about
yourself through the process of this
journey well the number one thing that I
learned is that I wasn't as ready as I
said that I was in receiving love and
receiving love really yes I'm looking
for an amazing partner a good friend a
good bonus person to my son you know
someone who I can bounce ideas off of
and grow with and grow old with and you
know for lifer that's what I'm looking
for Tamar's love story is even flowing
into her music just listen to her new
song changed
[Music]
much
it's the Grammy nominees first single in
six years you know I just had to
speak about what I was going through
which is well I was single for a very
very long time looking for love being
let down
and trying to figure out where I fit you
know with love and I had to write about
that so love is inspiring and inspiring
me good and bad okay I mean it is that's
the thing about dating you can always
get a good story you know hello and
Tamar and Jr are ready for their next
chapter they've been engaged for six
months and are busy planning the wedding
of their dreams
you're making me the happiest man in the
whole world I'm very sure I'm confident
I'm ready and let's see what happens
[Music]